Speaker 1: We have a really packed program today,
so I'm going to do everybody a favor and not
spend 5 minutes talking about how it's a packed
program and just get into the substance. They're
now trying to ban abortion nationally. I told you
this would happen. It wasn't just me. It's not a
pat on the back. It was very obvious. And many of
us were predicting after the Supreme Court made a
decision which overturned Roe v Wade, overturning
the fundamental right to an abortion in most cases
for in the United States. We had this prediction
that this was only the beginning. Now, why was it
such an obvious prediction? Well, you don't get
your biggest win and then stop. I mean, you know,
even Michael Jordan won three championships
before he temporarily retired and then came
back and then won three more. Would have been
weird to just win that first one and then say,
see everybody later. On the one hand, there were
the sort of more obvious predictions. Well, once
you overturn the right to an abortion, the next
thing is you try to ban it outright. You go beyond
just overturning it as a right. You say, let's
make this illegal. And then beyond that, it's
maybe they'll try to overturn the gay marriage
decision from 2015. And on the far end, it's.
Well, do they want to try to overturn interracial
marriage? Much more far fetched. But the point is,
you don't stop after your biggest victory. And
now, indeed, Lindsey Graham has introduced a
nationwide abortion ban just weeks after he said,
well, that's something that should be left up
to the states. Lindsey Graham is a hypocrite, of
course, but that's not really what this is about.
This is really about the obvious predictability
that this is something they were going to try to
do. As Rolling Stone writes, Lindsey Graham
introduced a federal abortion ban Tuesday,
weeks after declaring it's an issue that should be
left to the states. I think we should have a law
at the federal level, says Lindsey, that would
say that after 15 weeks, no abortion on demand.
Now, on demand is another one of these propaganda
terms. What does it mean on demand? It's like
you could just add it to anything. Well, I don't
know. What about knee replacement on demand? We're
talking about the exact same process by which you
consult with a doctor, and then a decision is made
and a procedure is either done or not done at the
agreement of the doctor and the patient on demand
is another one of these phrases that's just
meant to make things seem completely out of
control. Anyway, as Rolling Stone writes, Graham
wants to overrule the right of states to set their
own abortion laws, despite having said on several
occasions it should actually be decided by states,
not the federal government. Just last month, he
said, quote, I think states should decide the
issue of marriage and states should decide the
issue of abortion. So they're trying to do it.
Talking Points Memo Article Republicans move
to ban abortion nationwide. And it also this
particular article goes on to talk about the
bigger picture strategy. And there is some
risk to this strategy. And this is kind of where
I want to focus in, because we we knew they were
going to do this. And how they're going to do it
is obvious, but it's all totally predictable when
you look at polling, abortion being legal in most
cases is quite popular with Americans. In fact,
Americans are very divided about so many different
issues. But abortion being legal in most cases
is one of the issues on which Americans are
relatively united. You see significantly more than
60% support for that. And so there's a risk and
we'll see in November whether that risk ends up
damaging Republicans. There's a risk that if you
focus too much on banning and preventing abortion,
that you will lose support and that you will
lose elections. So there is a political risk
here for sure. When you are loudly running against
something that is popular nationally. There's a
couple of possibilities now. One possibility,
and this is very dark and I hope that this
isn't the case, is if Republicans are so sure
that now they've got it successfully rigged,
because remember, in 2020, they tried to steal
it, but they failed while accusing the left of
trying to steal it, which of course, the
left wasn't doing. If for 2022, in 2024,
they're feeling more confident in their ability
to take elections, that the will of the people
doesn't actually show them winning. Then they
could say, well, we know how to win regardless
of what people want, so let's go ahead and
try to ban abortion. That's one possibility.
The other possibility is that this is a terrible
miscalculation because because they correctly
recognize that being against abortion is still
a great way to raise money from certain groups,
but it has become decoupled from support out in
the general population. So they're interested.
They see, oh, if we if we do this, if we try to
ban abortion, these moneyed groups will give us
a ton of money, but we're going to lose a lot of
the people. So it could be a miscalculation. And
then the third one, which I don't think there's
really evidence for, is they're intentionally
sabotaging themselves. I mean, I'm including it in
the list, but it doesn't seem particularly likely
that that's what's going on. And then the fourth
possibility also is they just disagree with the
polling. They might just say we don't agree that
two thirds of Americans, as every poll shows,
believe abortion should be legal. In most cases.
We think the polling is wrong and we think this is
a winning way forward. Now, whether they will
even get a vote on this remains a question.
Mitch McConnell was asked about it yesterday. He
didn't really answer. So we're going to continue
following it, but not a surprise to anybody who's
been paying attention after overturning Roe v
Wade. The next step is let's see about a federal
ban on abortion. We'll see where it gets them. I